[Music]
the physician
has always regarded house calls as a
part of his duty to his patients
and for years nursing service has been
available to patients at home
through public health departments and
visiting nurse associations
physical and occupational therapists too
have made their services available to
invalids in their homes
recently a new member of the medical
team has made it possible to offer
more extensive home care to patients
this is the home health aide
[Music]
foreign
anyone in the community might someday
need the services of the home health
aide
[Music]
a typical story might begin here
or here in a hospital before the home
health aide begins her job
a referral must first be made by the
patient's physician to the home health
agency
the patient suffered a broken hip eight
weeks ago
recent x-rays indicate to her physician
that the bone is knitting satisfactorily
and that the patient lowe will soon be
ready for discharge from the hospital
[Music]
the attending physician informs mrs lowe
and her niece
of the good news but before setting a
final departure date
the doctor conducts an evaluation
conference on her case
with him are the hospital nursing
supervisor
public health nursing coordinator social
worker
and the physical therapist who has been
working with mrs lowe
uh do you feel satisfied from a
physiotherapy standpoint then that mrs
lowe has made satisfactory progress
yes mrs law is ambulating very well with
the stationary walker
the physical therapist reports that the
patient's progress has been good
but that she will need to continue
walking exercise under supervision
since other aspects of her case indicate
satisfactory recovery the doctor can
order mrs lowe's discharge
the physical therapist is instructed to
demonstrate the walking exercise to the
public health nurse assigned to the case
the public health nurse will in turn
supervise a home health aide
and make weekly checks of the patient's
progress
with the services of the public health
nurse and the home health aide available
mrs lowe can look forward to going home
an early discharge is important to mrs
lowe
and to the hospital where continuing
care is available
the patient can recover at home and
release a valuable hospital bed for a
more critical case
here in the familiar surroundings of her
own home
mrs lowe will receive assistance in her
personal care
as long as needed since she is over 65
the patient is eligible for medicare or
health insurance for the agent under the
social security act
well now since you're over 65 years old
medicare is going to help you oh i'm so
glad somebody's going to help me
although my niece helps me so much then
i have another daughter too that helps
me
good well since you are under medicare
they help to pay your hospital bill well
that's good i'm glad to hear that
and in addition your doctor has ordered
a home health aide
to come in here and give you daily care
with the things that you can't do by
yourself she'll be here shortly and you
can meet her
here's a list of the things that she
will be able to do for you
the home health aide is the newest
member of the medical team
her job is to extend personal care to a
patient at home
working under the supervision of a
public health nurse
the home health aide will call on mrs
law every weekday
on weekends the patient's niece will
care for her
the niece too will do the shopping for
food and other items necessary for her
as care
for the most part the home health aide
is concerned with direct
personal care and safety of the patient
her duties closely parallel those of a
nurse's aid in a hospital or nursing
home
among these are assisting the patient in
using the toilet or bedpan
and in paving
the care of the patient's mouth skin and
hair are also duties of the aid
but the home health aide is not a
personal servant and she encourages the
patient to care for herself
whenever possible the patient's bedding
is examined daily for cleanliness and
comfort
and changed if necessary
[Music]
while housekeeping is not normally a
duty of a home health aide
she may perform simple household tasks
that relate directly to a healthful
environment for the patient
in this case the aids duties might
include meal preparation
since the patient lives alone and can
stand or walk for only short periods
she cannot easily prepare balanced meals
for herself
hot lunches are prepared daily
casseroles and other dishes are made
frequently since these may be easily
reheated by the patient for dinner
[Music]
diets are prepared according to
instructions from the doctor
in keeping with the patient's personal
likes and dislikes
[Music]
while it would be simple to serve the
patient with a tray the aide urges her
to seat herself at the table
it's one of the many steps towards
self-sufficiency for the patient
[Music]
the aid is trained to observe patient
condition and behavior
if a physical problem is noticed or if a
patient complains
the aide is instructed to call the
nursing office at once
[Music]
the nursing supervisor will contact the
public health nurse assigned to the case
she in turn will report the problem to
the patient's doctor
here the problem is simple mrs lowe
placed too much weight on her leg
too soon
in each case the public health nurse is
the on-the-job supervisor of the home
health aide
the nurse in turn is carrying out the
instructions of the attending physician
and others on the medical team
the home health aide is authorized to
carry out only those instructions which
are issued by the public health nurse
good morning may i see the supervisor
yes
karate and she's expecting you each week
the home health aide has a brief meeting
with her nursing supervisor
good morning
that's your new schedule the supervisor
reviews the following week's schedule
with the aid
then discusses any problems which may
have arisen
well feel well in a way but she isn't
eating too well
she isn't are you having does she when
you're there
yeah she eats when i'm there but she
won't fix it for herself
maybe you ought to try that business
that you did with mr burnside when you
brought in the tv trace and fixed
uh a little bit of a complete meal on
the tv tray and left it in the ice box
forty so
she can work real well that way she
could just put that in the oven
and she wouldn't have to spend time
walking around that way that's right
that might be a good idea to make your
emergency visits and you found out that
the nursing supervisor holds periodic
meetings with her home
health aide staff here she distributes
helpful printed material
and can describe new policies and
developments which affect home health
aides
well what did you think about the book
that we used i liked it very much
did you like it did you get a good
chance to use it yes it is
i heard you talking about the book this
week what did you think of it well i
think it's very good especially this
uh here with that one patient of mine he
can't get up out of the bottom of the
bathtub when he's
oh this is from cheer businesses she
puts the chair in the
bathtub as of now but she's going to get
one of the items that is
demonstrated in the book mrs docker you
took the book out to your arthritic
patient the other day didn't you
no this is the first time i had had the
book the staff meeting serves as a forum
too where aids can raise questions
exchange information
the last time i didn't get to use these
gadgets because uh
patient i had is an arthritic and she i
had to get in the shower with her
and put on one of those plastic
raincoats that cover your head and all
take off my shoes and socks
well that was really an experience well
i'm glad you could laugh about it
i think some of the new class of home
health aides that we're training right
now would be interested in hearing some
of these
experiences they will be soon ready to
go out on observation visits with some
of you
and i will be arranging for these with
you the public health nurse will be
going in first
good home health aides don't just happen
they are carefully selected and trained
the advantages and disadvantages the
responsibilities
and the rewards of the job must be made
clear
with the public health nurse to plan
what you can do the good
home health aide is an emotionally
mature person
perhaps one who has raised a family they
get satisfaction from working with
people
and they are patient and understanding
with the sick
and their families you would ask her any
questions that you would have
about the care of the patient another
thing
is the activities of daily living to
make the patient
as training progresses the student aides
are given lectures and demonstrations by
qualified members of the medical team
for a patient without full flexion of
his body or full use of the
extremities and enables him to put on
his shoes by himself
she isn't having any support here where
the bend is in the bed
students take turns playing the part of
the patient
whenever possible the demonstrations
simulate actual conditions
to help them walk to a chair it's best
to help them
sit on the edge of the bed first so that
you can help them get their robe on and
help
slip on their slippers
then to help them slide out and give
them support as they help the patient
with their soup
if you dip it up and then run your spoon
with the cooperation of a hospital or
nursing home
students can practice with special
equipment
now if you'll try one
you don't want to have it too fully you
can see the nurse trying to move the
patient over in the bed
and you can see that she stands quite
close to the bed
has her back quite straight in this
slide
it demonstrates even more so why she
uses this position and
the value of this position
or a patient may have cheese
it can be a hard cheese or
cottage cheese in an effective home
health aid training program
study materials are plentiful and
students are expected to read
and understand them
students are tested and evaluated during
their training program
successful completion of the course
gives a trainee confidence in herself
and justifiable pride in what she has
learned
and earned her effort may be rewarded by
a certificate of completion
or a badge
mrs dishman
congratulations thank you very much
mr kingman the man we're going to see
now
is a stroke patient he's progressing
nicely now but
you should have seen after she has been
employed by an agency each new age
should have the opportunity to observe
work in the field
often a public health nurse will conduct
this orientation tour
alone invalid unable to care for himself
he is equally unable to care for his
living quarters
the results of neglect are often
unpleasant
sometimes shocking
so one of the first jobs of the aid is
restoring a healthful environment
and the rewards can be gratifying
in the past months this patient has made
a marked improvement
through the teamwork of his doctor the
occupational therapist
the public health nurse and the home
health aide
a rehabilitation program guided by the
occupational therapist has enabled this
patient to learn to perform simple tasks
for himself
[Music]
complete recovery may not be possible
for this patient
he will always require some personal
help
but his newfound self-sufficiency has
postponed the day when he needs
full-time
care in a nursing home
[Music]
he is a lady with multiple sclerosis
we've been carrying her for about a year
and a half and
find she's a very interesting patient
really wanting to help herself
do as much as she can but she has a
husband who works
during the week and a boy who goes to
school
so therefore she's left alone most of
the time we go in and help her
how long have she been like this several
years now
mrs whittaker helps her do this
sometimes she can get
close enough to the table and we know
not all cases handled by the home health
aide involve the care of the elderly
under medicare
like the public health nurses her case
load will vary
as a rule a doctor will request the need
for the service of a home health aide
when there are no family members present
who can give care to the patient
fees for home health aid service are
handled on a partial or full payment
scale
similar to fees for public health nurses
some health insurance plans absorb
part of this cost
[Music]
the aid must understand how much
assistance
and what kind of assistance to give to
the patient to help her maintain
[Music]
[Applause]
self-reliance
in each case the duties of the home
health aid are clearly outlined
and scheduled at no time does the aid
give
care which has not been prescribed
[Music]
the student aide is learning firsthand
about these responsibilities
soon she'll be given assignments where
she'll make her own contributions as a
part of the medical team
[Music]
for the others the work goes on often to
a happy ending
[Music]
mrs lowe for example has recovered
satisfactorily at home
in a short time her position will
terminate the services of the home
health aide
the aids role has been important
providing
personal care the valuable link between
the patient
and medical care personnel properly
utilized
her skills will broaden the availability
of medical service and care
and will give greater scope and
flexibility to the other members
of the medical team
[Music]
dedication service responsibility
this is the home health aide
you